okay so we're going down this path of
split time opposites flower patterns and
one of the ones are going to be working
with a lot is box for petal anti-spin so
I've learned in the last few years that
a great way to learn or teach this share
this with somebody else is to actually
use an object so I put a box on a stick
and that's gonna be our object but if
you're showing this to somebody you can
use use your fist put your fist out and
tell the person you're showing see the
Box fist bump
the progression goes like this you build
it up slowly starting with two sides of
the box at a time so you start with
painting the top of the box which it's
pretty easy to do just really imagine a
paintbrush paint paint and then you go
top side you really want to see you're
making as clear a stroke along the whole
face of the box top inside you can go in
either direction top side probably pick
one direction at first top side and we
can clearly see you're doing that pick
the next two sides side bottom side
bottom you work your way around the box
bottom side bottom side until you get to
side top side top and you're back where
you started when you can do two sides
all the way around clearly in each
direction go two three
where you go top side bottom top side
bottom once you can do three sides all
the way around
top side bottom or side bottom side or
bottom side top and eventually side top
side you're in both directions graduate
to doing all four sides now this might
take days or weeks flowers really comes
slowly with practice but eventually
you're painting all four sides
I'd see top side bottom side top side
bottom side topside topside bottom side
side bottom weight side bottom side
topside topside side top and you're
rocking your four pedal box it's been
both hands both directions this box is
bigger than it needs to be
it's the box that I had certainly such a
big box you can use a doorknob or you
can use anything or a friend's fist and
in my experience it really does help
so dial those in both arms both
directions and then we will proceed in
to split time opposites awesomeness with
all the variations of boxes and stars
[Music]